[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public 90 minutes
de débats et de reportage comme tous les
jours sur public Senna 90 minutes pour
donner du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
experts et voici le sommaire de ceux 30
mars tarification progressive
réutilisation des eaux usées sobriété
pour tous avenir des méga bassines le
plan o annoncé par Emmanuel Macron se
vote ambitieux des actions d'urgence
pour répondre au deuxième été consécutif
de sécheresse qui s'annonce des
investissements à long terme aussi comme
pour permettre à nos centrales
nucléaires très gourmandes en eau de
fonctionner en circuit fermé on va
décortiquer ces mesures juste après les
titres et puis pour notre second débat
c'est un gigantesque bras de fer
économique quasiment passé sur les
radars médiatiques que l'on va vous
raconter en plein cœur de l'été dernier
à la mi-août le président américain
annonce sa grande loi pour le climat et
contre l'inflation je suis sur le point
de promulguer l'inflation Redemption
acte l'une des lois les plus importantes
de notre histoire
permettez-moi de le dire d'emblée avec
cette loi le peuple américain a gagné et
les intérêts particuliers ont perdu Joe
Biden aurait pu ajouter à sa liste des
perdants l'Europe car les subventions
proposées aux entreprises sont-elles que
des grands projets par exemple d'usine
de batterie électrique sont des gens en
train de se relocaliser aux États-Unis
bref c'est du protectionnisme et un
nouveau une nouvelle mondialisation qui
se mette en place vous verrez mais
d'abord la France face à la sécheresse
et ce plan o annoncé par un président de
la République qui avait bien besoin
d'une diversion ccsu il y a une
contestation sociale qui existe sur une
réforme mais ça veut pas dire que tout
doit s'arrêter Emmanuel Macron veut
tourner la page au bord du lac de
Serre-Ponçon il est venu présenter son
plan pour améliorer la gestion de l'eau
malgré les 200 manifestants venus lui
rappeler leur mécontentement sur la
réforme des retraites premier objectif
pour le président faire 10% d'économie
d'eau dans tous les secteurs d'ici à
2030 nous allons demander à chaque
secteur un plan de sob sur l'eau d'ici à
l'été les ministres réuniront dans les
prochains jours dans l'ensemble des
secteurs concernés l'énergie l'industrie
le tourisme les loisirs l'agriculture ça
marche bien quand tout le monde sait
l'évolution de la situation quand tout
le monde est responsabilisé et quand on
sait que les efforts sont partagés ils
proposent notamment la mise en place
d'un éco-watt de l'eau une application
pour suivre sa consommation sur le même
modèle qui existe pour l'électricité
autre mesure aider les communes à
refaire leur canalisation aujourd'hui en
mauvais état elle perdent 50% de l'eau
qui circule enfin il souhaite mettre en
place une tarification progressive de
l'eau les prix des premiers mètres cubes
seront modestes et augmenteront ensuite
au-delà d'un certain niveau
le prix du mètre cube sera plus élevé et
c'est normal pour les consommations que
j'appellerai de confort et pour inciter
à la sobriété le président a également
annoncé vouloir augmenter à 10% la
réutilisation des eaux usées d'ici à
2030 aujourd'hui seulement 1% de ses
eaux sont retraités et c'est évidemment
l'une des mesures annoncées l'une des
ambitions que l'on va décortiquer avec
mes invités Marie Pétain Natti bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes hydrogéologue au
bureau de recherche géologique et
minières Nicolas Garnier bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi directeur général
de l'association
amorce qui regroupe alors j'ai pas
pouvoir faire toute la liste il y a des
communes collectivités locales syndicats
d'économie mix et puis des partenaires
en matière de gestion de déchets de
réseaux de chaleur ou d'énergie Franck
Galand bonsoir bienvenue bonsoir vous
êtes chercheur associé à la Fondation
pour la recherche stratégique et présent
de la société de conseils
environnemental emergency et security
service bienvenue à vous bienvenue et
bonsoir Mathilde Mathilde Sirault
éditorialise politique je commence par
le constat je vous demande presque à pas
le faire m'a répété Natti mais on en est
au final le niveau de nos nappes
phréatiques est-il historiquement bas
aujourd'hui oui Thomas le niveau de nos
nappe est historiquement bas aujourd'hui
on a plus de 80% des niveaux qui sont
bas à très bas sur tout le territoire on
a encore une recharge qui a été tardif
cet automne et puis on a eu un épisode
non plus vieux cet hiver plus 32 jours
consécutifs sans pluie qui fait que on
n'a pas pu recharger ses nappes et ses
nappes elles sont très importantes parce
que c'est notre stock d'eau il faut
savoir que ça représente plus de 60% de
ces eaux qui sont utilisés pour l'eau
potable pour l'alimentation en eau
potable donc pour tout usage également
mais c'est très important que de
d'octobre à peu près au mois d'avril là
c'est qu'on est des pluies importantes
pour que ces nappes aient efficace pour
que c'est nappes puissent se recharger
il y a des mesures d'urgence on va on va
détailler un peu ce que ce que Emmanuel
Macron a lancé dans le cas du plan mais
des mesures d'urgence est-ce que des
mesures d'urgence peuvent suffire dans
un contexte comme celui-là vous voyez ce
que je veux dire alors
les mesures d'urgence comme vous le
dites c'est des mesures très courtes
thermistes et on en a besoin et le
premier réflexe effectivement sont les
mesures de restriction sont décidés par
les préfets on a déjà 32 départements
qui sont sous ces sous ces restrictions
à différents niveaux il y a des niveaux
de vigilance et il y a déjà des niveaux
d'alerte notamment dans les dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône alors ça suffit pas à
long terme parce que on est dans un
contexte de changement climatique on l'a
dit on l'a vu le rapport du GIEC le
reprécise et montre les conséquences
terribles que cela peut avoir sur l'eau
avec des températures qui augmentent les
vapo transpiration augmentent et donc on
a de moins en moins de recharge de nos
stocks et de ses nappes et donc c'est
pour ça qu'il y a aussi des mesures de
de long terme Nicolas Garnier ce plan
haut
finalement on y reviendra annoncer par
le Président de la République est-ce que
vous trouvez à la hauteur des enjeux pas
seulement du court terme là pour le coup
les enjeux globaux
je fais pas de politique ma réponse est
oui ma réponse est oui clairement on
attendait la dernière fois que je suis
venu sur ce plateau c'était pour vous
dire il manque une loi il manque une
remettre l'eau au coeur de la transition
écologique je crois que ça a été fait en
tout cas dans la parole présidentielle
d'abord c'est le président qui parle ça
veut dire quelque chose peut-être qu'il
y a d'autres raisons mais ça veut dire
quelque chose
il fixe des objectifs en particulier de
sobriété qu'on connaissait mais qu'on
n'avait pas appliqué et là derrière il y
a un plan d'action qui permet de penser
que c'est réalisable
il donne aussi des pistes de gouvernance
intéressante parce que si ça a pas été
réalisé c'est parce qu'en fait c'est
très important de le dire c'est que
quand on fait un effort environnemental
je pourrais vous dire la même chose dans
les déchets énergiques qui sont les
autres domaines amorce il faut se
répartir l'effort si vous répartissez
pas l'effort en faisant de sa faute
c'est le monde agricole etc ça ne
fonctionne jamais très là il y a l'idée
de répartir l'effort dans le temps en
tracteur et par territoire car chaque
territoire devra faire son moins 10
d'une certaine manière et là il y a une
idée de gouvernance qui est très
intéressante et puis il propose des
moyens en tout cas il a évoqué
il la propose par exemple la levée du
plafond mordant qui est une demande que
les collectivités ont fait de plusieurs
c'est un petit peu compliqué mais c'est
pour ça que je vous relance en fait dans
le prix de l'eau un Français paye à peu
près 4,3 € le mètre cube la moyenne
nationale en fait il y a une partie du
prix qui finance les installations la
station d'épuration la station de
pompage les canalisations et puis il y a
une partie c'est une un prélèvement
qu'on va dire quasi fiscal qui sont les
redevances de l'eau qui alimentent les
agences de l'eau et qui vont leur
permettre de de financer leur programme
d'accompagnement sauf qu'aujourd'hui
c'est prélèvements ils sont capés par
l'État et au-dessus d'une certaine
quantité de prélèvement l'état garder la
somme donc en fait on pouvait avoir
besoin de plus d'argent pour accompagner
l'eau l'état dit au-dessus de 2,1
milliard c'est pour moi et donc on était
capé et l'État généré de la recette pour
son budget général ce qui était assez
scandaleux les élus se sont beaucoup
battus contre ça c'est une mesure
symbolique très forte parce que ça il y
avait une sorte de comment dire de
procès en un sincérité c'est à dire on
lève une révolution
Oslo et puis on en fait autre chose et
puis ça ça permet d'avoir plus de moyens
je vais faire peut-être là sur
interprétation mais une parole très très
importante il dit à un moment donné il
va y avoir plus d'argent pour les
agences de l'eau comme il n'y a pas
d'argent magique il va falloir générer
cette recette on parle de 500 millions
d'euros là le chiffre qui a été annoncé
une partie c'est ce que je viens de vous
dire c'est parce qu'on va rendre de
l'argent qu'on prélever déjà mais qui
était qui allait vers Bercy l'autre
partie va falloir générer et là c'est un
sujet très important c'est que
aujourd'hui tout le monde ne paye pas
l'eau de la même manière en fait tout le
monde est focalisé sur les usages de
Messi que le visage pour la brosse à
dents etc ou là vous payez une redevance
assez importante de quelques dizaines de
centimes d'euros par mètre cube mais par
contre les autres usages le monde
agricole paye presque rien le monde
industriel perd presque rien les
fameuses centrales nucléaires ils
peuvent presque rien et là ce qu'on
sous-entend nous parlant cette
intervention c'est enfin il va y avoir
une rééquilibrage dans le signal prix
parce qu'on va parler du signal prix si
globalement le monde agricole le monde
industriel à l'eau gratuitement pas
espérer qu'il se passe grand chose en
terme d'économie alors votre avis
là-dessus également le fait que
effectivement on parla beaucoup plus de
l'agriculture après peut-être qu'on peut
se concentrer sur le l'industrie le
monde industriel il va devoir plus entre
guillemets cotisé j'allais dire c'est
pas le bon terme mais participer à
l'oeuvre collective déjà en terme de
sobriété de sobriété et puis en terme de
participation financière est-ce que ça
vous semble logique finalement
l'industrie en France c'est 10 % des
prélèvements c'est 6 % des consommations
de loin l'industrie le secteur
industrielle n'est pas le plus grand
consommateur d'eau de métropole alors le
premier aujourd'hui c'est l'irrigation
effectivement avec 44% vient après
l'alimentation en eau potable des
populations à hauteur de 24%. alors ce
qui est très intéressant dans les
paroles du Président c'est cette
ambition de 10% et à l'évidence le
secteur industriel va devoir mettre en
place d'abord une meilleure connaissance
de son empreinte en eau au niveau de ses
activités de process au delà de ça se
mettre à être effectivement plus sobre
donc réparer un certain nombre de fuites
potentiellement après compteur vous
utilisez ces forages par exemple et
introduire
typiquement des modules de réutilisation
des eaux usées qui vont permettre
d'utiliser cette offre en eau
alternative pour le process industriel
alors ça va d'abord s'adapter ça doit
d'abord s'adapter à l'industrie
pétrochimique très consommatrice d'eau
l'industrie pepetière et à l'industrie
agroalimentaire et là on retrouve
la dualité eau et agriculture et sur le
coup de l'eau ce dont nous parler
Nicolas Garnier alors les annonces du
président de la République vont encore
une fois dans le bon sens c'est-à-dire
que plus vous allez consommer plus vous
allez payer donc il va falloir vous
adapter domestiquement nos familles et
les industriels vont devoir le faire
mais au-delà des industriels il y a tous
les utilisateurs de l'énergie parce que
pour l'énergie il faut de l'eau
et il y a un effort éminent à faire au
niveau typiquement des opérateurs de
data center les opérateurs de datacenter
consomment de l'eau prenez un datacenter
moyen allez c'est 1750 mètres cubes par
an j'ai un exemple de natation c'est
pour rafraîchir rafraîchir les centres
serveurs qui permettent à nous
smartphone de fonctionner prenons un
data center classique qui devait
s'ouvrir à charpe 1750 mètres cubes par
an 1200 mètres cubes uniquement pour le
refroidissement de cette data center
c'est à dire que c'est un bâtiment
tertiaire normal normalement il doit
utiliser 550 mètres cubes d'eau par an
pour l'espace vert pour l'eau sanitaire
pour l'eau le chauffage etc bon bah
voilà le sujet il est sur tous ces
usages aussi indirects de l'eau et ça il
va falloir faire des annonces très très
claires pour rendre typiquement nos
opérateurs de datacenter plus sobre sur
leur utilisation donc pour vous la
tarification progressive de l'eau ça va
dans le bon sens et est-ce qu'en terme
de moyens alloués par l'État et annoncer
aujourd'hui par le président le tout ce
qu'il a parti financement ça vous semble
à la hauteur des enjeux concernant
peut-être un mot rapide là-dessus rapide
s'il vous plaît Nicolas Garnier alors
déjà la tarification progressive telle
qu'elle a été annoncée par le président
était plutôt sur le domestique depuis
qu'on a compris nous ce qu'on dit c'est
il faut commencer aussi il faut aussi
que l'industriel c'est un peu
l'interprétation qu'on en a eu se fasse
effectivement nous on a des
collectivités qui font déjà ces
tarifications progressives Dunkerque
Montpellier ont mis en place un
dispositif d'ailleurs on me dit
progressif c'est les premiers mètres CUB
vraiment pas cher c'est ce qui a été
très bien dit les premiers mètres que
vraiment pas cher parce que on en a
assez vital c'est pour boire les mètres
cubes du milieu si vous me permettez au
même prix et ce qu'il faut qu'on invente
c'est la surtaxe de la sur tarification
du du mètre cube en trop le mètre cube
pour laver sa voiture le mètre cube
pendant la pour avoir une sensation de
responsabiliser les Français absolument
ça ça demande quelques à accompagnements
particuliers il faut avoir accès au
nombre de personnes dans le logement par
exemple sinon vous allez faire des
choses inéquitables vous allez
sanctionner les familles nombreuses
choses comme ça et effectivement il y a
un outil qui a pas été clairement dit
c'est le le dispositif d'accompagnement
on pense à une aide des agences de l'eau
en faveur des collectivités je mettrai
ses tarifications parce qu'il y a un
problème de administrative va falloir
créer des fichiers entiers de est-ce que
tu consommes trop ou pas assez donc il y
a quand même du travail on pense à une
aide des agences de l'eau mais peut-être
qu'il y aura des modulations divers et
variées ça pas été clairement annoncé
comment on allait nous engager fortement
c'est quand même du travail market c'est
quoi l'annonce la plus importante du
jour pour vous elle annonce la plus
importante du jour il y en a beaucoup
pour moi
aujourd'hui et bien c'est peut-être sur
les mesures d'adaptation les efforts qui
va falloir faire et notamment par
rapport à la réutilisation des eaux
usées traitées qui va ouvrir un vrai
champ en fait de solution qu'on va
pouvoir mettre en place à l'échelle de
chaque territoire la réutilisation de
usées traités c'est pas seulement
prendre l'eau à la sortie de la station
d'épuration et aller l'utiliser pour
arroser sa pelouse ou
remplir sa piscine avec pas du tout ça
va être une vraie étude économique sur
chaque territoire est-ce que côté
pertinent de le faire quels
usage quelle quantité quelle différente
qualité d'eau aussi en fonction des
traitements quel traitement sont
nécessaires combien coûte ces
traitements est-ce qu'il va falloir
rénover une partie des stations
d'épuration peut-être que j'anticipe sur
votre question d'abord ça tombe bien
parce que c'était vraiment un des focus
que je voulais faire un peu plus tard
dans le débat mais je voulais quand même
avoir votre votre avis un peu un peu
général sur le sur le plan annoncé par
Emmanuel Macron qui était donc Mathilde
au lac de Serre-Ponçon visite qui était
pas tout à fait au programme on peut
dire ça comme ça on peut même dire au
contraire Thomas que ce sont les
circonstances politiques sur le front
des retraites qui ont conduit Emmanuel
Macron effectivement à se déplacer
aujourd'hui à Savines-le-Lac le plan o
était bel et bien à l'agenda du
gouvernement depuis même plusieurs
semaines maintenant mais ça devait être
la première ministre Elisabeth borne et
le ministre de la transition écologique
Christophe Béchu qui devait le porter le
contenu d'ailleurs de ce plan ne
justifie pas a priori une intervention
du président non pas que ce sujet soit
secondaire bien au contraire mais la
planification écologique en tant que
telle est dû ressort de la première
ministre d'ailleurs sur ce sujet c'est
la première ministre qui avait annoncé
le plan de sobriétaire énergétique qui
consistait à faire baisser de 10% notre
consommation d'énergie la même logique
que le président a reprises aujourd'hui
sur l'eau alors on s'en doute un peu
mais qu'est-ce qu'il a conduit le
président de la République a
s'approprier ce dossier plusieurs
raisons Thomas d'abord depuis le début
de l'année on a très peu vu le président
sur le terrain national il y a eu un peu
des visites les vœux aux armées à
Mont-de-Marsan le salon de l'agriculture
mais plusieurs déplacements avaient été
reportés notamment sa tournée à
Marseille à cause des retraites le plan
o c'est donc un très bon prétexte pour
Emmanuel Macron en pleine crise sociale
et politique de montrer qu'il n'est pas
claque muré à l'Elysée que le palais de
l'Elysée n'est pas devenu une espèce de
bunker au moment où beaucoup de
commentaires ciblent un supposé
isolement ou enfermement du président et
d'ailleurs pour appuyer ce signal il ne
sait pas contenter d'un discours il
s'est plié à l'exercice qu'on appelle
dans notre jargon journalistique le
micro tendu pour répondre aux questions
des journalistes qui est-ce qui lui a pu
lui permettre de distiller quelques
messages politiques il a montré aussi
dans la scénographie qu'il n'était pas
seul mais entouré d'élus le format était
plutôt autour d'une table ronde un
discours plutôt ramassé devant un public
trié sur le volet évidemment il n'a pas
croisé les manifestants et ça c'était
pour la forme sur le fond Thomas le
président a fait coup double il
réapparaît d'abord sur un sujet de
préoccupation pour les Français la
sécheresse et donc plus globalement sur
l'écologie l'écologie qu'il a listé
parmi les priorités de l'après retraite
il tisse le fil du récit sur la fin de
l'abondance des ressources et cette
sortie a le mérite de braquer évidemment
les projecteurs sur un autre sujet que
les 64 ans et les manifestations il
s'expriment aussi sur l'eau en plein
mouvement contre les retenues d'eau
justement dans les Deux Sèvres 4 jours
après des scènes de chaos de sainte
Soline il a choisi de cliver vis-à-vis
des écolos et des activistes mobilisés
contre ces méga bassines il a parlé de
ces milliers de gens qui étaient venus
pour faire la guerre une stratégie plus
ou moins à qui tout double puisque l'un
de ses proches avec qui j'ai pu échanger
me disait cette sortie ne va pas
arranger son image c'est presque de la
provoque vu le contexte d'aller se payer
les écolos merci beaucoup Mathilde on
reparlera des des méga bassines tout à
l'heure mais je voudrais ouvrir le
chapitre des eaux usées avec quelques
chiffres que l'on a déjà donné sur ce
plateau mais que je vous redonne la
France se réutilise seulement 1% de ses
eaux usées alors on est loin de la
moyenne européenne c'est 3% on est
encore
très loin de nouveaux en espagnol 14 %
très très loin d'Israël 90% l'objectif
annoncé par Emmanuel Macron c'est
d'atteindre les 10% en 2030 Galand alors
déjà il faut commencer par quoi il faut
changer la réglementation c'est quoi le
les les différentes étapes une évidence
faire évoluer la réglementation
la technologie est là aujourd'hui pour
preuve vous avez des modules de
réutilisation des eaux usées en compteur
20 pieds qui se mettent en sortie de
station de traitement d'eau usées et qui
permet d'économiser comme Veolia le fait
par exemple sur Narbonne sur Rodez 20000
m3 ça sert à nettoyer des camions par
exemple ça sert à arroser les espaces
verts
qui dit canicule dit sécheresse dit
multiplication des incendies de forêts
on a malheureusement brûlé 10 fois plus
d'hectares l'été dernier 70 000 hectares
sont partis en fumée et bien la
réutilisation des eaux usées peut
permettre à certains endroits d'arroser
préventivement les couverts forestiers
donc on a on a de multiples usages pour
ça il va falloir que la législation nous
permettent de le faire mais l'Europe et
ça je parle sur le contrôle de de mes
deux collègues l'Europe va aussi nous
obliger rendre cette extension de leur
utilisation des eaux usées possibles on
voit bien que l'Espagne confronter un
climat soumis à des réalités depuis 40
ans si est adapté par la réutilisation
des eaux usées ou si vous citiez le
chiffre de 14% par le dessalement et de
ce point de vue là je suis je suis un
peu étonné moi de pas avoir eu le mot
décemment dans le discours du président
de la République pourquoi parce que je
pense qu'aujourd'hui vu les conditions
sécheresse auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés c'est une solution qui ne
faut pas s'interdire on l'a vu l'été
dernier sur certaines îles bretonnes qui
ont été sauvées je pense à l'île de
Groix par les stations mobiles de
dessalement une ville comme Barcelone
aujourd'hui à une station de dessalement
qui couvre 20% de ses besoins 200 000 m3
la ville de Londres on ne le sait pas
juste avant les Jeux Olympiques de 2012
une station de dessalement a été
inaugurée pour couvrir 6% des besoins en
eau David lelongue à Ostende une sur le
canal au stand Bruges une session des
salmon de 12000 mètres cubes par jour a
été récemment inauguré donc il faut pas
s'interdire les solutions techniques
qu'est-ce qui bloque si on fait un petit
parce qu'on a encore dans le système
actuel ma répéter Natti la
réglementation ça c'est un vrai frein
qu'est ce que ça nous empêche de faire
par rapport à nos voisins espagnols ou
italien par exemple alors la
réglementation elle existe en France sur
la réutilisation il y a un arrêté
national qui a été mis en 2014 qui
catégorise 4 types d'eau en fonction des
usages en fonction d'arrosage d'espaces
publics en fonction d'irrigation de
culture donc ça existe c'est encadré par
contre
et bien malheureusement j'ai envie de
vous dire la loi qui va européenne qui
va rentrer en force en 2023 donc en juin
de cette année va être plus stricte au
niveau des niveaux c'est niveau de
qualité concernent uniquement les
niveaux pathogènes et matières en
suspension donc c'est niveau là il va
falloir pour les les les
comment dire les sites existants de
réutilisation de usées traités direct il
va falloir je dis direct parce que c'est
lorsqu'on utilise cette eau directement
à la
fait partie de la station d'épuration
après traitement il va falloir adapter
adapter ses niveaux et forcément adapter
certainement les traitements ou les
temps de résidence dans les dans la
chaîne de traitement dans les usages de
ces eaux grises ou ces eaux usées est-ce
qu'on peut je peux vraiment des
questions de bossiens est-ce qu'on peut
recharger une nappe phréatique avec ça
oui tout à fait alors en France pour
l'instant ça n'existe pas par contre
parce que la réglementation interdit ou
parce que on n'a pas on s'est dit on en
avait pas besoin on est plutôt un pays
béni des dieux en matière de ressources
en eau et donc on sait pas poser la
question la deuxième option il faut pas
confondre une interdiction et ce qui
n'est pas forcément autorisé c'est un
petit c'est un petit peu subtil mais
c'est un petit peu le cas en France
lorsqu'on veut faire une implémentation
de système de recharge maîtrisé donc
j'explique ce que c'est ça à partir du
nom on va recharger les nappes
phréatiques pour disposer d'une
meilleure qualité de cette eau de nappe
c'est aussi dans cet objectif ou d'une
quantité plus importante donc sur la
recherche des aquifères à partir de
usées traités on n'a pas de cas en
France on a en Californie un énorme sasa
ils sont précurseurs on a une énorme
usine de traitement on est à plus de 500
000 mètres cubes jours traiter en
Californie à partir des eaux
usées de Los Angeles ils utilisent une
chaîne de traitement qui est assez
complexe qui passe par l'ultrafiltration
par l'osmose inverse on nettoie l'eau on
la purifie énormément il y a un système
de d'ultraviolet aussi parce que
attention dans ces traités on peut
retrouver des molécules qui peuvent être
très très très dangereuses avec la santé
publique et voilà exactement comme les
les nitrosamides qui sont vraiment des
molécules cancérogènes qui peuvent poser
problème donc il faut tout système de
traitement en tout cas pour pour faire
très attention et ensuite on réinjecte
en Californie alors ils sont très très à
cheval ils vont pousser les traitements
très loin pour l'acceptation sociale
aussi il réinjecte les os ensuite dans
la nappe pour les utiliser ce que je
retiens et ce qui est rassurant c'est
que les solutions techniques on les a
bon voilà après il faut il va falloir
les investissements etc il y a des
communes qui sont qui sont plutôt en
avance sur la réutilisation des des oui
d'ailleurs il faut bien il y a
différents scénarios d'abord il y a
plusieurs eaux qu'on peut réutiliser il
y a on pense aux eaux de sortie station
d'épuration mais par exemple il y a des
collectivités qui récupèrent les autres
piscines les autres piscines municipales
pour faire du lavage de véhicules pour
faire du lavage de voirie il y a des
collectivités qui développent de la
réutilisation d'eau gris c'est à dire
nos eaux domestiques de vaisselle et de
pour faire de l'usage dans les toilettes
des choses comme ça et puis il y a les
grands usages dont on vient de parler
c'est à dire des usages agricoles donc
et des usages non agricoles on pense au
golf on pense aussi à d'autres je dis
d'ailleurs on le sait pas mais il y a on
a même un cas en France d'une
collectivité c'est le syndicat de la
Vendée qui fait avec des eaux usées de
l'eau potable ça s'appelle Jourdain le
programme voilà c'est le programme c'est
Monsieur Jourdain et effectivement donc
ça c'est quand même très intéressant
d'ailleurs si on s'en donne les moyens
en termes de traitement en tenant compte
des des réserves qui ont été apportées
on sait faire de l'eau potable avec de
l'eau usée c'est de l'eau simplement il
faut extraire la partie la partie
potable donc le potentiel sur le reute
est très important après il y a quand
même une petite modération qu'il faut
qu'on vous qu'on partage avec les
spectateurs c'est des fois c'est très
pertinent des fois ça l'est pas du tout
c'est à dire que si vous êtes en bord de
mer
détournez votre station d'épuration de
la rivière qui va se jeter dans la mer
qui va se saliniser donc en fait vous
êtes un peu en train tu me permettait
pas de gâcher l'eau mais enfin vous
allez pas pouvoir la réutiliser pour
refaire du captage là c'est très
intéressant de faire du riz donc en bord
de mer dans ses bas qui de rivières qui
vont dans la mer c'est très intéressant
parce que ça va permettre de d'éviter
effectivement de pomper de l'eau qui va
réduire les nappes et les nappes est en
vides on va voir ce qu'on appelle des
biseau salés c'est à dire que la mer va
rentrer dans ses nappes et va s'aligner
l'eau potable donc en board en littoral
très intéressant il y a d'autres vidéos
réutilisation il y a d'autres zones où
finalement vous avez besoin de mettre
cette eau de sortie station d'épuration
dans la rivière parce que si Annie va
pas votre rivière elle est à sec parce
qu'en fait une grande partie de l'eau de
la rivière vient de la station
d'épuration là il faut pas le faire
parce que sinon vous avez pu aller plus
d'eau alors
ça nous pose la question du de l'échelon
territorial et c'est justement l'un des
thèmes de la chronique de terme traduit
qui va nous rejoindre tout de suite sur
ce plateau bonsoir tu as bienvenu
puisque on va se rendre compte que le
plan o implant haut c'est ce qui réclame
de nombreux sénateurs et depuis
longtemps et oui 144 sénateurs beaucoup
de LR et de centriste mais aussi
quelques communistes et Renaissance mais
pas d'écologie c'est une socialiste on
va comprendre pourquoi on d'ailleurs
cosigné une tribune publiée dans le
Journal du Dimanche je te le 18 mars
dernier on envoie le titre le
gouvernement n'a pas pris la mesure des
sécheresses Disney parlementaires leurs
craintes que l'on reproduit sur l'eau
les
errements français sur l'électricité où
on est passé d'une électricité abondante
et bon marché grâce aux nucléaire donc
on comprend la pourquoi il n'y a pas
d'écologie ce qui est à cossigné à
l'incertitude et à des risques de
coupure les fameux délestages auxquels
on a échappé cet hiver on voit également
qu'ils disent et bien donc aujourd'hui
l'électricité demain l'eau demande des
sénateurs il faut bien le parallèle ils
craignent que l'on passe donc sur l'eau
d'une France riche en eau bon marché
avec une géographie avantageuse entre
cours d'eau et des pluies jusque là
suffisantes à une France qui manquera
dos entre les sécheresses et le
vieillissement des réseaux d'adduction
les conduites et autres ouvrages qui
conduisent l'eau de la source à nos
habitations que propose-t-il pour ne pas
reproduire ce scénario et bien ils
invitent à se plonger dans un rapport
sur l'eau qui a été écrit l'automne
dernier par la délégation de la
prospective du Sénat dont le but comme
son nom l'indique est de se projeter
d'anticiper et d'éviter la panne sèche
et oui nos élus ont un petit peu
d'humour un rapport c'est le nom du
rapport évitez la peine sèche rapport
signé donc de parlementaires communistes
Renaissance LR alors quelques priorités
dégagées allez vers plus de sobriété et
ça repose au moins sur vous et moi on
l'a bien compris que sur le secteur de
l'agriculture autre proposition
réutilisée les eaux usées vous en avez
parlé également et également avoir une
approche pragmatique des retenues d'eau
ce sont là les mots dessinateurs en
clair il parle et bien des bassines des
méga bassines comme celle de sainte
Soline on les sans prendre bien sûr des
gants en abordant ce sujet ils disent
que c'est retenu doivent pas donner le
sentiment aux agriculteurs qui peuvent
consommer plus d'eau mais que je les
cite disqualifier globalement le
stockage d'eau ne paraît pas fondé
scientifiquement il plaide finalement
pour la construction de nouvelles
retenues multi-usages par exemple pour
lutter contre les feux de forêt enfin le
sujet le plus clivant ce n'est pas
celui-là ce n'est pas celui des bassines
c'est celui de la gouvernance de l'eau
c'est là qu'il y a alors quel est ceci
quel problème le problème c'est que
d'ici 2026 la loi notre impose que la
gestion de l'eau soit transférée des
communes à l'intercommunalité le
transfert de la compétence au
assainissement et bien c'est un serpent
de mer de plusieurs années un vrai sujet
de conflit pour le gouvernement avec les
maires dont les sénateurs qui sont les
élus des maires se font les porte-voix
les sénateurs estiment et bien que ce
transfert de compétences peut être dans
certaines situations une bonne idée mais
parfois c'est complètement inadapté les
mers ruraux et de communes de montagne
notamment son vent debout écoutez ce
maire que nous avions interrogé Sandra
sarquera la vie interrogé en 2019 il
explique pourquoi je suis donc le
président des six communes qui
regroupent le syndicat intercommunal des
eaux du Gonesse que l'on voit ici en
orange et nous allons passer sans
commune donc on a actuellement un
service qui fonctionne très bien et qui
est très réactif dans l'heure qui suit
les services sont sur place pour réparer
la fuite à l'avenir est-ce qu'on aura
encore la réactivité c'est pas sûr du
tout puisque le périmètre sera beaucoup
plus étendu on se pose des questions
pourquoi fusionner et enlever et
supprimer un service qui fonctionne très
bien alors il y a eu beaucoup
d'assouplissements accordés par des lois
successives sur ce transfert de
compétences mais ce n'est toujours pas
suffisant pour les mères et pour les
sénateurs bref Flo un sujet donc
doublement explosif pour l'exécutif
entre les oppositions citoyennes à
générer par les bassines et la levée de
boucliers des élus sur cette compétence
eau et assainissement merci Tom pour
pour ces explications Marie pété Matisse
et c'est quoi le bon échelon puisque là
on parle d'une gestion ce qui est
intéressant c'est cette notion d'une
gestion collective de l'eau il faut que
tout le monde s'y mette à la fois sur la
sobriété puis sur l'anticipation c'est
quoi le bon échelon c'est c'est le
territoire c'est chaque territoire assez
problématiques au niveau de ses besoins
en eau au niveau au niveau de son
économie et de sa ressource de la
disponibilité de sa ressource
on est divisé en 7 bassin avec des sous
bassins et puis ensuite on a des comités
de bassin où se prennent des décisions
et ensuite on décline ça aussi sur sur
chaque territoire dans ce qu'on appelle
les ptge les projets de territoire pour
la question de de boutique un peu mais
entre communes et intercommunalité parce
que là on voit que les sénateurs vont te
créneau là-dessus ça pour vous ça change
vraiment quelque chose ça ça peut
changer quelque chose parce que en
fonction de l'intercommunalité les
problématiques seront peut-être pas les
mêmes d'une commune et une autre donc il
va falloir il va falloir avoir de la
solidarité aussi c'est à dire que entre
ces communes il peut y avoir du
transfert aussi de compétences ou du
transfert d'information mais en tout cas
la meilleure la meilleure gestion
effectivement elle est au niveau local
parce que c'est à ce niveau là que les
compétences et les connaissances de la
ressource aussi
d'ailleurs franglais c'était l'un des
aspects du du discours d'Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui le la notion la notion du
territoriale et de solidarité à
l'évidence la solution de l'eau passe
par les interconnexions
et en particulier en situation d'urgence
alors je reviens cet échelon
intercommunale et communal il est
intéressant de voir que quand il y a une
crise dans le domaine de l'eau et
rappelons que la mission
interministérielle 2022 l'a montré on a
eu 1052 communes qui ont manqué d'eau
l'été dernier et plus d'un millier qui
sont pas passés loin de la correctionnel
vous avez aimé 2022 vous allez adorer
2023 ça en prend le chemin donc on va
doubler on va pas ça peut être pire on
va pas on va pas aller dans la
sinistralité par rapport au niveau des
fortes que ce soit bien fort probable et
donc ça veut dire
qui viennent pour pour alimenter reste
directeur des opérations de secours le
secours aux populations n'est pas géré
au niveau de l'intercommunalité donc il
va falloir à la faveur du transfert de
la responsabilité au niveau de
l'intercommunalité il va falloir aussi
penser
la gestion au niveau des
intercommunalités de la sauvegarde des
populations alors la loi matras est
passée par là au niveau de la refonte de
la sécurité civile en France et donc on
va vers des plans intercommunaux de
sauvegarde ça ça prend un excellent
chemin mais là les annonces du président
de la République vont espérons nous
porter leurs fruits à horizon 2030 c'est
la limite qui nous est fixée mais
comment ont passé tes prochains comment
on passe l'été 2024 juste avant les JO
l'imaginer la situation donc il va
falloir aller vers des plans d'ultime
secours il va falloir organiser
typiquement le site internet organisé la
distribution d'eau bouteilles aux
populations vous savez il y a une crise
qui a frappé la ville de Dunkerque en
avril 2019 le syndicat des eaux du
Dunkerquois sont délégataires Suez ont
bien géré les choses c'était pas une
problématique c'est très c'est une
problématique de casse majeure suite à
un tunnelier qu'il a heurté ils ont
distribué 600 000 bouteilles d'eau en 4
jours ça a été une opération logistique
immense et tout ça ma doit s'organiser
votre avis là dessus également Nicolas
Garnier parce que voilà vous représentez
aussi les communes et les
intercommunalités etc enfin surtout je
reprends besoin d'abord les
intercommunalités les communes et même
les régions en fait vous il y a deux
questions dans votre question le premier
c'est on a une gouvernance de l'eau qui
est très complexe on a des on a parlé de
bassin donc en fait le bassin c'est ce
qui est autour d'un fleuve pour faire
simple les sous bassins c'est ce qui est
autour d'une rivière mais à côté de ça
vous avez une une gouvernance
administrative qui est plutôt la Région
le Département donc il se parle pas
vraiment c'est à dire vous avez des ce
qu'on appelle des dages des schémas
directeurs à l'échelle des fleuves qui
disent des choses et puis à côté de ça
vous avez les régions les stradettes les
schémas régionaux qui disent d'autres
choses ensuite dessous il y a vraiment
il y a des endroits il y a des zones
blanches par exemple tout à l'heure tu
parlais des PT ge et des des plans
territoriaux de gestion de l'eau
d'accord il y en a pas donc en fait en
dessous il y a des endroits il y a des
zones blanches il y a on ne cause pas
d'eau pour faire simple c'est un peu
simplifier mais ça moitié de la France à
peu près d'accord la moitié la France il
y a pas de décision prise non parce
qu'il y a quand même une compétences
opérationnelle qui est la commune et
l'intercommunalité et ensuite à quelque
chose pour vous parler des déchets
énergie haut c'est qu'il y a beaucoup
plus il y a une fragmentation des
collectivités dans le service public de
l'eau qu'on n'a pas dans le domaine des
déchets ou de l'énergie c'est très
fragmenté il y a 25 ou 26000 services
publics d'eau qui sont généralement
intercommunalisés mais des fois c'est
une commune seule donc là il y a
effectivement quand on traite des sujets
de biodiversité de sécheresse il y a
quand même une masse critique donc faut
qu'on trouve un une sorte de compromis
entre garder Homer sa capacité de
proximité et d'intervention et en même
temps de se donner les les mailles
suffisantes pour pour mutualiser une
vision pour faire une nouvelle station
d'épuration etc je reprends la main
parce que le temps file c'est bon signe
ça veut dire que c'est passionnant mais
encore plein de thèmes à aborder je vois
évidemment qu'on parle de l'agriculture
et des méga bassines on est au cœur de
de l'actualité c'est presque deux
visions qui qui s'opposent alors il y a
celles et ceux qui refusent les méga
bassines comme Clémence guetter député
LFI qui était à Sainte Soline samedi on
l'écoute
à une minorité au détriment de la
majorité au détriment de nous toutes et
tous et je ne voudrais pas qu'on se
réveille dans quelques dizaines d'années
en se disant mince c'était vraiment une
grosse connerie on a détruit les nappes
il y a plus d'eau il y a plus
d'agriculture il y a plus moyen de se
nourrir donc c'est pour ça aujourd'hui
qu'on lutte c'est pour les années à
venir et puis à celles et ceux qui
défendent les stockage d'eau au nom de
la vitalité des territoires notamment
comme Jean-Luc cap qui est président de
l'Association de Gestion de l'irrigation
landaise c'était aussi lors d'une
manifestation à Mont-de-Marsan je vous
ai proposé des baisses autour de 20 30%
des volumes qui sont catastrophiques
pour notre agriculture locale par
rapport à tout ce que ça représente
comme transformation sur le terrain quel
que soit les productions que ce soit par
rapport à des légumes que ce soit par
rapport à des céréales comme le maïs qui
est transformé de par des productions
animales locales et c'est un enjeu de la
vitalité de notre territoire Marie pétée
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de la logique
Ann par le gouvernement consiste à dire
on autorise des méga bassines à
condition qu'il y ait des engagements
des agriculteurs sur on va dire la
transformation du modèle vers un modèle
plus écologiquement plus plus vertueux
est-ce que c'est suffisamment exigeant
finalement les les engagements qu'on
demande aux agriculteurs la gestion
intégrée de la ressource en eau elle
passe pas par une vision manichéenne des
choses c'est impossible on doit passer
par ce qu'on appelle le mixhydrique
comme le mix énergétique en fait par un
nombre de solutions qui va être mis en
place sur chaque territoire donc on peut
des endroits où une méga bassine ça peut
pouvoir s'imposer et il y en a d'autres
c'est une aberration de la de la creusée
c'est pareil ça va être ça va être comme
tout système qui va avoir une emprise
comme la recharge maîtrisée des
accuseurs ne sera pas pertinente sur
certains endroits donc c'est chaque
solution qui va falloir penser au niveau
de chaque territoire mais il va falloir
intégrer le changement climatique dedans
et c'est peut-être ce qui n'a pas été
fait sur certaines installations donc
les méga bassines pour l'instant elle
elles sont aussi une traduction d'un
d'un temps où il a fallu apporter des
solutions sur le territoire pour les
agriculteurs mais maintenant il faut
penser à ce mix de solution et ce qui
n'a peut-être pas été assez évoqué ou
mis en avant ce matin mais je suis sûr
qu'il se trouve quelque part dans le
plan haut en détail c'est les solutions
font des sur la nature pour retenir
l'eau sur les territoires et qui sont
aussi dans ce que disent les
agriculteurs aussi comme effort à faire
sur sur leur schéma sur leur trajectoire
futures Nicolas Garnier est-ce que
là-dessus sur le donnant donnant on va
dire méga bassines et agriculture plus
écologique vous êtes satisfait du
discours présidentiel ou est-ce qu'il y
a des zones des zones d'ombre de flou
non c'est vrai que c'est vraiment l'un
des sujets les plus compliqués en plus
il est très équivant donc c'est vous
imaginez quand vous représentez les élus
locaux si vous dites je suis pour des
matières des des élus etc mais en ce qui
peut être quand même intéressant c'est
la deuxième partie de la phrase mais
j'ai conscience de beauté un peu en tout
je sais que si ça peut être une manière
d'accompagner massivement les
changements de mode d'agriculture ça
peut être intéressant parce que
fondamentalement les premières méga
bassines c'était quand même des méga
basites qui ne pensaient pas une
évolution du mode agricole c'était j'ai
besoin d'eau oui c'était au contraire
j'ai besoin d'eau pour mon maïs etc
perdurer le modèle ancien quoi tandis
que là ce qui est bien c'est que tout
d'un coup les deux logiques se
commencent à se rapprocher c'est de dire
bon là je suis assez d'accord ça sera du
cas par cas pertinence non pertinence on
regardait ça etc mais surtout de dire
par contre on vous accompagne sur le
changement de modèle et là il y a
quelque chose qui se joue rendez compte
par exemple on va on n'a pas beaucoup
parlé de de protection qualitative on
n'a pas beaucoup parlé de polo depuis le
début
moitié il y a deux gens bien protéger
quantitativement l'eau protégé
qualitativement le fait de se dire
qu'aujourd'hui on est obligé d'assurer
des traitements sur les métabolites de
pesticides métabolites de pesticides le
le ce qui reste des pesticides on nous
collectivités on est obligé de mettre en
place des traitements pour empêcher de
dépasser des normes normes sur des des
sites qui sont pas interdits sur les
zones de captage de l'eau potable et on
dit non vous pouvez pas nous demander de
traiter sans interdire et de et donc il
y a vraiment des enjeux extrêmement
forts sur des mutations du monde
agricole c'est peut-être l'occasion
puisqu'ils sont j'allais dire challenger
de dire ok mais vous vous on va vous
accompagner vous vous engagez à changer
de modèle autre avantage c'est que ça
redimensionne et bassine parce que du
coup les bassines vous en avez besoin
d'une quantité si vous restez dans votre
modèle c'est plus les mêmes bassines si
vous changez de modèle à 5 ou 10 ans
donc il y a quelque chose c'est pas
c'est j'ai conscience que je bote un peu
en touche mais il y a quelque chose
d'intéressant qui se joue entre l'Ancien
Monde et le Nouveau Monde l'un un modèle
et un autre dans le fait de dire vous
allez évoluer vous mangue agricoles et
ça ça a été bien dit par le Président
j'ai deux thèmes à traiter mais j'ai
plus le temps de faire les deux
qu'est-ce que vous préférez la lutte
contre les fuites ou le ou le nucléaire
c'est moi qui suis obligé de choisir bon
allez je vais faire la lutte contre les
fuites et puis on va écouter pour lancer
ce thème chiffres est faux le le
secrétaire national on va y revenir du
Parti communiste français il réclamait
un plan d'investissement enfin mais
aussi évidemment c'était lors du Salon
de l'Agriculture écoutez la sobriété
c'est important
il y a moins d'eau et donc oui il faudra
en consommer moins mais aujourd'hui la
première chose à faire c'est un vaste
plan d'investissement pour récupérer
toute l'eau qui part dans des fuites qui
existent dans tout le réseau d'eau en
France il a été vendu au privé il y a
l'équivalent de 3500 piscines olympiques
perdues tous les ans à cause de ses
fuites alors il a été on peut le dire
une certaine façon entendu Fabien
Roussel Emmanuel Macron annonce 180
millions d'euros par an pour résorber en
urgence les fuites il y a dit-il 170
points noirs déjà identifiés font galant
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour
rattraper ce que les uns les autres
décrivent comme un sous-investissement
chronique depuis des années à changer un
maître linéaire de réseau c'est 315
euros
sous nos pieds en France c'est 900000 km
de réseau c'est 23,5 fois le tour de la
terre donc aujourd'hui on n'a pas 50%
effectivement de fuite à certains
endroits il y a 50% de fuite et le
président de la République se propose
d'aider toutes ses collectivités qui
veulent diminuer
plutôt augmenter le rendement de réseau
diminue leur fuite parce qu'on donnait
le chiffre de 50% de fuite au niveau
national donc c'est 20% c'est déjà pour
ça les objectifs du Grenelle 2 de
l'environnement de 2010 avait pour Dieu
objectif 15%. donc il faut tendre vers
cet objectif de 15 % si possible aller
vers l'objectif de 10 % comme Toulouse
Métropole est en train de le faire par
exemple mais je vous interrompre parce
que qui a sous-investi parce que là dans
le l'interview de Fabien Roussel il y a
une critique contre la privatisation de
l'eau non le problème de l'eau c'est que
ça ne se voit pas notre patrimoine il
est enterré
vous savez des délégataires ont des
obligations contractuelles très très
fortes aujourd'hui sur le rendement de
réseau donc quand on leur donne les
moyens et quand l'autorité organisatrice
leur dit l'objectif c'est effectivement
ça je peux vous assurer qu'un opérateur
privé mais on place tout ce qu'il faut
et avec science et conscience ce que
technicien ingénieur savent faire ça
mais même chose au niveau des régies
publiques qui aujourd'hui ont un
objectif de diminution de leur perte en
eau techniquement là aussi ma répéter
n'a pas très compliqué de ça me semble
pas très compliqué mais vous l'avez dit
c'est un coup en fait donc on a des ça
coûte très cher il y a des systèmes
assez performants pour détecter des
fuites voilà les identifier et ensuite
c'est voilà c'est c'est du chantier
c'est beaucoup et donc c'est de
l'investissement alors je repose ma
question un peu différemment Nicolas
Garnier qui va toucher l'argent
débloquer par l'État quand on parle de
180 millions d'euros par an c'est les
communes qui vont les ensuite les les
reverser aux sociétés privées qui gèrent
l'eau comment ça va se passer déjà il y
a pas que des sociétés
aujourd'hui dans plutôt dans un
équilibre entre des des gestions privées
déjà options publiques au passage le
plus important c'est savoir comment
pilote ces sociétés publiques ou privées
c'est plutôt que le montage soit vous
êtes une bonne collectivité qui fixe des
objectifs en particulier qui les
contrôlent et qui les contrôlent et qui
les sanctionne en cas de non-attente et
auquel cas que ce soit une régie ou une
despe vous faites faire le job euh
Délégation de Service délégation de
service public mais effectivement
aujourd'hui on pense que cet argent là
va arriver dans le monde de jaillir sur
le patrimoine des collectivités locales
d'ailleurs c'est bien dit c'est que
c'est le résultat d'une histoire c'est
pas d'une mauvaise gestion c'est que
c'était tellement cher et tellement
important qu'on l'a pas fait j'aurais
quand même revenir sur une deux choses
sur les fuites la porte d'abord la
première des fuites c'est tous les
captages qui ne sont pas comptés ça peut
vous surprendre de dire ça mais ça a été
peu dit mais il y a encore beaucoup de
gens qui captent de l'eau et qui sont en
dehors des radars moi j'appelle ça une
fuite parce que quelque part il
disparaissent des bilans s'approprie ne
devrait pas s'approprier dans le monde
agricole mais dans le monde individuel
il y a des gens qui font des puits etc
donc la première des filles c'est tous
ces gens qui captent de l'eau et ça soit
pas il y a une autre fille dont il faut
qu'on parle un jour c'est ce qui se
passe dans nos maisons c'est à dire
qu'on pense qu'il y a aussi un niveau de
perte de fuite dans les réseaux j'allais
dire après le compteur donc il y a un
sujet sur les réseaux on en a parlé il y
a aussi un sujet après le compteur parce
que chez vous et moi vous avez ça vous
avez peut-être déjà arrivé d'avoir une
fuite chez vous d'ailleurs et des fois
ça peut durer longtemps d'accord donc il
y a aussi un travail à faire dans le
patrimoine bâti ça nous amène d'ailleurs
sur un sujet important c'est qu'il faut
qu'on apprenne à construire autrement
nos maisons pour récupérer depuis pour
mettre des mousseurs pour avoir des
chasses d'eau double vitesse il y a tort
ça a été dit par votre chroniqueuse je
crois qu'il y a quand même aussi un beau
potentiel d'économie chez chacun d'entre
nous par nos comportement mais aussi par
notre matériel la manière dont on
construit les maisons doit changer elle
est à dernier moment mais rapidement
parce que c'est la fin du mois
exactement dans le sens des forages non
identifié à propos des vols d'eau on a
énormément de vols d'eau depuis des
bornes potos incendie et ça faut que ça
cesse
au nom de l'intérêt général et d'autant
plus en situation de sécheresse et je
vais vous donner le mot de la conclusion
parce que est-ce que c'est si grave les
fuites d'eau parce qu'elle repartent
dans la nature tout est à prendre en
compte en période de stress hydrique on
doit tout prendre en compte et on doit
s'organiser pour pour être optimisé la
gestion de la ressource en eau voilà ce
sera le mot de la fois merci beaucoup on
peut dire qu'il faut boire l'eau du
robinet ah bah moi c'est très important
elle est ultra ultra contrôlée l'eau du
robinet buvait l'eau du robinet
évidemment merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat et à bientôt sur
sur public